the division that the cowboys are a
member of
is owned right now by the washington
football team a team that may be known
as the washington football team and
definitely i like the name
i like the move to get ryan fitzpatrick
as the quarterback
here's quarterback ryan fitzpatrick
explaining today why he signed
with the washington football team well i
mean the number one thing i was looking
for in
free agency was just a chance to play
a place that was going to allow me to
compete to be the guy
and so that was number one and obviously
washington
was a team that had that and you know
aside from that when you
when i started to narrow it down just i
think coach rivera the culture that's
being created
uh the youthful energy in the building
you know playoffs last year it was seven
and nine but
it was playoffs and i think that this
team
you know there's a lot of optimism and
there's some good juju in the building
so i think a lot of those things
factored into it
there is a good vibe right now with the
washington football team
it seems like they are getting things
right systematically
gradually i still want to see what
happens with the ongoing investigation
into years of workplace misconduct i
want to see what the league
does to daniel snyder we can talk about
that more in a second
as it relates to the football team
though ryan fitzpatrick now again you
know how i feel about the fitzpatrick
if it's magic fits tragic toggle switch
every time we think he's good
he does something to convince us that he
isn't and then when we've written him
off
he becomes dan marino in his prime but
they could have done a lot worse
their options behind him are not great
and they're in a spot in round one
where they hardly would have any
confidence that they could
just sit there and wait for a
quarterback to fall into their laps so
they made their move they were
aggressive and again they could do a lot
worse than ryan fitzpatrick
and given that they're in such a weak
division he's an upgrade everything
they've done so far this year
is upgrade over what they were last year
when they were good enough to win the
division
so i made an internal bet with myself uh
whether or not you would go
over or under 10 seconds before saying
fits magic to fitz tragic
and i've actually lost the bet yeah i
know it's unfortunate that it was over
but i like to build up to it yeah you do
but
it's inevitable i know well now i know
see next time
i do it i do it because it is as
inevitable
as fits magic too fits tragic that's why
i do it it's a
metaphor i think well maybe but i
the weird thing to me about this and
this fits magic
probably fits tragic situation that
could eventually happen
is that i don't feel like ryan
fitzpatrick has gone too many teams that
just went to the playoffs before so in
this way it's almost a bit of a new
situation i mean he said
that he this is the most sought after
he's been in his career
you know after he of course he went to
harvard i'm not sure if you knew that
mike but you know he's been in the
league
for over a year don't know what you're
talking about and i want you to stop
well you know he's an ivy league guy so
am i i guess i just had to throw that in
there
um but when you look at him now he's
just somebody that i think
can help elevate that kind of offense
and he's better
as a quarterback than what they had
before so
that at least you know when you have a
good defense and you have guys like
curtis samuel terry mclaurin that he's
going to be able to throw the ball to
i think that helps him and maybe that
means that they can prevent the fitz
tragic from happening
maybe a little bit quicker than it would
otherwise
we saw him with the tampa bay buccaneers
and i think that was when
the the swing was the most
notorious that great game on a monday
night where he did have plenty of
mistakes
but then he did some awesome things for
the buccaneers against the pittsburgh
steelers when jameis winston was
suspended a couple of years ago
but hey i admire the fact that the guy
has now played for more than 25 percent
of the nfl's teams
he still keeps going he's contemplated
retirement
in the past but i think he's come
to terms with the idea that there's only
so many years he's going to be able to
play
just play while you can and then when
you're retired you're retired i got a
lot of respect for what he's done
but we have to be realistic about the
possibility
that yes he may ultimately
end up giving us some moments where we
ask ourselves what in the world is the
washington
football team doing do we have the
updated odds
from points bet for the nfc champion i
assume washington is still the favorite
after winning it last year and making
the most moves so far this year the
giants have done some things
i don't know how i feel about what the
giants have done i forgot doubt it's
just because it's dallas
every year we think dallas is gonna be
good and every year they urinate down
their lag miles
well but if that prescott is healthy
then
that is probably gonna make them better
i feel like if doc prescott had been
healthy all last year
even despite how bad that defense was
that offense was really good
so they might have been able to go a
nade and win that division if that
prescott
were healthy for the entire season and
it's not to say that andy dalton did
that horrible of a job but i
when dak is out there he makes a
difference which is why he just got the
contract that he received so i mean
to me if you're factoring in the
offensive stuff and
you're thinking that dak prescott will
be healthy then it kind of makes sense
to me
that dallas would be the favorite in
that division
the issue with daniel snyder buying out
the 40.5 percent of the team owned by
fred smith robert rothman and dwight
schar
the nfl approving next week it's
expected this will happen
the request by snyder to bust through
the league's debt ceiling so he can
finance this transaction
anywhere from 875 to 950 million to buy
these guys out
that is an indication i believe and i've
been told that
the league is not going to force him to
forfeit the franchise there had been
some reporting a couple of weeks ago
based upon
preliminary or expected findings from
beth wilkinson who's been performing the
investigation
into workplace misconduct that she would
recommend
a forced sale of the team and sims and i
talked about this today miles and i
think it bears repeating to the extent
that anyone
didn't see the morning show and they're
watching us now and if if
you are thank you for watching now but
why didn't you watch in the morning you
would have learned about
chocolate-covered pretzels as well if
you had watched in the morning
but i really do think the league is not
going to force this guy to sell for
these types of allegations
because the other owners do not want
that kind
of a precedent and there may be others
who already
we don't know but who would be worrying
about
based upon lawsuits that have been
settled that the league maybe does or
doesn't know about or people who could
come out of the woodwork
and just make allegations that maybe
aren't completely true
but would be enough to get that that
unblinking red eye of the league office
to focus on them next so
i think that has a lot to do with why
daniel snyder won't be forced to sell i
expect him to be
heavily fined i wouldn't be stunned if
he's suspended although
what does it mean to suspend an owner if
you don't take away the profits that the
team makes
during the period of the suspension but
you know that is on one hand
a good thing that they're cleaning up
the messes that have been made in the
past it's part of this sense that the
team's on the right track
but at the end of the day dana schneider
owns 100 of the team we'll see whether
or not he's truly changed
or whether or not he's just acting like
he's changed
because he knows that the alternative
is at some point they're going to make
you sell the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports